y
bienvenidos a el debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález haití vuelve a
estar en el centro del debate
internacional y también es parte del
interés de la comunidad mundial esta vez
por un hecho gravísimo que amenaza con
desatar una crisis política e
institucional de grandes magnitudes en
ese país caribeño y también puede
generar una crisis regional la madrugada
del 7 de julio un grupo de hombres
fuertemente armados y entrenados
irrumpieron en la residencia privada del
presidente juvenil moix en un barrio de
la ciudad de puerto príncipe la capital
haitiana una vez dentro de la
edificación dispararon provocando la
muerte del mandatario y dejando también
gravemente herida a la primera dama
martín mucho el hecho por supuesto
conmocionó a la región y también generó
incertidumbre sobre el rumbo que puede
tomar haití más detalles se los damos en
el siguiente informe que hemos preparado
para ustedes
haití primer país independiente de
américa latina y actualmente también el
más pobre de la región 11 2 millones de
habitantes viven en este país arrasado
en los últimos años por un terremoto en
2010 y el huracán matthew en 2016 tras
ambos desastres el país recibió gran
cantidad de ayuda internacional que ha
estado rodeada de interrogantes la deuda
externa del país superaba el 36 por
ciento en 2020 y la supuesta ayuda
internacional ha hecho haití más
dependiente del exterior la pobreza
arrasa la población haitiana los sueños
de la revolución de esclavos que la
llevó a la independencia nunca se
cumplieron se calcula que más del 20 por
ciento de la población vive bajo el
umbral de la extrema pobreza en este
contexto la crisis derivada de la
pandemia de kobe 19 sólo ha empeorado la
situación hay una crisis humanitaria con
escasez de alimentos ya que es de los
pocos países del mundo que no ha
recibido ninguna dosis de la vacuna a
todo esto se le suma la crisis política
que estalló en 2015 hubo comicios en los
que ganó job en el mois el mandatario
asesinado pero no fue reconocido por la
autoridad electoral
más de un año después allí comenzó la
controversia para moix en este momento
comenzaba su mandato para la oposición
un año antes
así moix defendía que su mandato
acabaría en 2022 cuando no se
presentaría a las elecciones el
parlamento está disuelto por decreto
desde enero de 2020 y la oposición ya no
reconocía la legitimidad de moix que
gobernaba ahora por decreto en febrero
de este año las calles estallaron en
protestas en esa fecha según la
oposición moix debería haber entregado
el poder desde entonces el gobierno de
moix detuvo a 20 opositores por supuesto
golpismo que más tarde fueron absueltos
por un tribunal móvil se había declarado
enemigo de la oligarquía que controla
los negocios claves como la banca o la
energía en un país que ha sufrido el
gran aumento del precio de los
combustibles ha grabado también por la
falta de envío de crudo desde venezuela
su otrora principal proveedor las bandas
siembran también al país de violencia y
se calcula que controlan hasta el 60 por
ciento del territorio sólo durante este
pasado junio ha muerto más de 150
personas y otras 200 han sido
secuestradas en el área metropolitana de
puerto príncipe
haití ha tenido más de 20 gobiernos en
35 años por el momento nadie ha
conseguido la estabilidad
pero haití es un país que desde hace
muchos años viene haciendo frente a
múltiples crisis inseguridad
inestabilidad un vacío político cuatro
millones de sus 11,5 millones de
habitantes están en inseguridad
alimentaria 2 millones de ellos han
tenido que dejar el país y buscar una
mejor vida en otros países como eeuu o
también en europa y en algunos países de
suramérica cerca de 200 secuestros
fueron contabilizados solamente en el
mes de junio y la economía pues marcha a
medias veamos algunas de las cifras que
preparó la redacción de economía de
france 24 la magnitud de este crimen
apenas se está dimensionando a nivel
internacional quienes pueden estar
entonces detrás de este asesinato
es una de las preguntas que queda sobre
la mesa según las autoridades de haití
según la policía nacional cuatro
posibles sospechosos de este grupo de
mercenarios fueron dados de baja en la
noche de ayer en enfrentamientos en
puerto príncipe- otros dos fueron
capturados y han sido identificados 28
y mercenarios de este grupo que entró de
una manera irregular al territorio
haitiano que viene entonces para este
país está lo suficientemente preparado
haití y lo suficientemente maduro
digámoslo así para poder hacer frente a
una crisis como ésta todo esto mientras
la primera dama martín moix está
luchando por su vida en un hospital de
la ciudad de miami ciudad a donde fue
trasladada para recuperarse de las
heridas que recibió en el ataque
seguimos por supuesto muy atentos a la
salud de ella la crisis y la situación
en haití es nuestro tema de debate en
france 24 múltiples aristas para
analizar este tema compleja la situación
allí está con nosotros desde la ciudad
de bogotá el señor jean maggie exile él
es embajador de haití ante la república
de colombia y también está con nosotros
desde la ciudad de puerto príncipe
colette de espinas ella es periodista
analista también es educadora de
derechos humanos y servicio social como
les decía se encuentra en la capital
haitiana
ustedes también nuestros televidentes
son parte de esta conversación a través
de las redes sociales pueden dejar
comentarios y preguntas
en nuestra cuenta de facebook también en
twitter o en instagram estamos como
france24
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal
pueden dejar los comentarios con el
numeral el debate efe 24 hay también una
encuesta en línea para que ustedes
opinen sobre esas elecciones que están
previstas para ser realizadas en el mes
de septiembre pues tenemos el tema
tenemos el contexto de los invitados
damos inicio entonces al debate y
comienzo entonces preguntándole al señor
exilio en la ciudad de bogotá sobre las
consecuencias que puede tener para haití
dado el contexto en el que se encuentra
este magnicidio que ocurrió y que
terminó con la vida del presidente moles
buenas noches a todos los integrantes de
france france 24 es un gusto para mí
estar con ustedes
debido a lo sucedido en haití con
nuestro presidente joven el morís lo que
viene pues la constitución haitiana está
muy grave
en este caso específicamente el artículo
149 de la constitución explica
el primer ministro de este momento que
es el señor cloud joseph es el que debe
de conducir en el disfrute del país
realizando las elecciones para
establecer el orden en nuestra nación
y colette en la ciudad de puerto
príncipe cuál es su opinión las
consecuencias que puede traer para su
país este magnicidio y le amplió un poco
más la pregunta esto es el comienzo de
un nuevo capítulo de inestabilidad
política y social en haití ya veíamos
que son múltiples los frentes y las
crisis que está haciendo el país
combatiendo lo desde hace ya varias
décadas
buenas noches a ustedes y también a
todas que están llegando ahora bueno
tarde también atendió al embajador el
día primero que este equipo con un
poquito sobre la constitución porque la
el artículo centro de 49 para mucha
gente muchos analistas en el país no
conviene en este caso porque dice muy
bien que si estamos en el último año de
la presidencia de un oscuro algo
normalmente deben de retomar en la
agresión del baile en el paramento
industrial bien para
es el caso ahora sin embargo para
médicos entonces no se puede utilizar
ese al círculo y además
el señor ya no es ministro porque ya no
es un mandato porque el presidente
que rechazamos en el país
[Música]
no puede volver de nuevo como primer
ministro y escribiendo en esta situación
es realmente un diálogo en el país para
votar
sí señor
si le había ampliado la pregunta y
quería saber si para usted entonces está
comenzando un nuevo capítulo de
inestabilidad política en haití después
de los hechos sucedidos
bueno eso es también una oportunidad
depende de cómo se va a gestionar este
capítulo puede abrir una oportunidad
para que esto dar un punto de toma de
conciencia de la situación actual y se
compromete a ajustar soluciones pero lo
que me inquieta personalmente como
ciudadanía ciudad a la ansiada de esta
manera como rápidamente y sin hablar con
ningún sector del país y el ex primer
ministro
cuando rápidamente para tomarla
a causa de graves de encontrar los
derechos humanos
y también como él está tomando
decisiones importantísimos con lo que
llamamos la comunidad internacional sin
ninguna
y oye muchas lecturas que la madre en
esos últimos dos brillas primero
condenado al asesinato del presidente de
goles pero también viendo algunos
receptores de ancianos que te ponen
juntos a buscar la solución a la
violencia existen muchas opositora son
agentes del embajador exile su opinión
es un nuevo capítulo es una oportunidad
hay un posible vacío de poder están las
garantías dadas para hacer una
transición que
y lleve a esas elecciones sin ninguna
complicación el mes de septiembre
como nuestra compatriota
colette
pues lo está manifestando creo que es el
momento de que nosotros los haitianos
tomamos conciencia de lo que estamos
haciéndonos y estamos construyendo en el
país es el momento para que nosotros
rompemos paradigmas para que es el
momento de que nosotros fortalecemos las
instituciones
llevamos después de la dictadura de
duvalier aproximadamente unos 30 años
peleando entre nosotros que no nos lleva
el país en ningún camino como usted bien
acabo de decirlo pues es el país más
empobrecido digamos en américa latina ya
es momento de hacer las cosas totalmente
diferentes es el momento de que tomamos
lo que es la conciencia colectiva
hacer las cosas como se debe de ser
rompiendo paradigmas y conducir el país
en un buen norte
embajador habla usted de romper
paradigmas de confiar en las
instituciones y de tomar un camino
diferente pero la institucionalidad de
haití está en las condiciones para
garantizar ese paso que tiene que dar el
país en este momento de coyuntura tan
difícil en donde pues como usted lo ve
para algunos ciudadanos el primer
ministro josep no debería estar
asumiendo este rol hay otro primer
ministro que fue elegido y que estaba a
la espera de asumir el cargo para muchos
hay un vacío de poder para muchos es
necesaria una acción desde el parlamento
desde la corte suprema de justicia y eso
genera incertidumbre sobre cómo puede
ser ese paso para salir de esta crisis
sí señor este es el tema de consenso
es tema de consenso no es tema
hoy en día de intereses particulares no
en nuestra sociedad ya debe debe de ver
y entender que estamos es una generación
perdida no 30 años peleando que nos
lleva el país en ningún camino todos los
sectores deben entrar en consensos para
armar las elecciones
en septiembre una segunda vuelta en
noviembre para que el 7 de febrero el
próximo presidente puede entrar en
función fortaleciendo aquellas
instituciones que estamos hablando en
este momento y conducirá el país en otro
camino
colette allí en la ciudad de puerto
príncipe la comunidad internacional
principalmente actores importantes como
por ejemplo eeuu un país que ha estado
ligado a la historia de haití también
francia la unión europea en general y
organismos continentales como la oea y
también naciones unidas- respaldaban el
gobierno del presidente moix de hecho
fue una de las bases o columnas que lo
mantuvo en el poder en esa disputa de si
debía o no dejar el cargo en ese año que
pues fue controvertido de si debía
gobernar él o entregar el poder y era el
final de esa fase de gobierno que pues
nunca quedó verdaderamente claro qué
papel va a jugar eeuu en esta crisis que
se ha desatado en haití qué papel va a
jugar francia la comunidad internacional
y otros países de la región como por
ejemplo república dominicana que es el
hermano directo comparten fronteras en
la misma isla
bueno quiero decir la receta de las
elecciones que todas estas
organizaciones internacionales y en los
eeuu están proponiendo para salir de la
crisis para mí y para muchos sectores de
la decimos van a ayudar en nada si las
elecciones de atenas turista lo que
tenemos que hacer direcciones que hacen
las condiciones actuales con cuando en
todas partes del país y con jugada pone
muchas personas eso ha sido el mismo
desplazamiento porque los grupos armados
sumaron su espacio de duda vamos a
agudizar la crisis no reconocerla
y espero que esta comunidad
internacional que entienda eso y apoya a
tres cuartos de los aislados ajustar
funciones de propiedades a su problema y
usted acaba habiendo intentado un ciclo
de la vialidad
pero nadie porque cuáles son los
problemas renales de lugares que pueden
explotar eso el problema de su lugar
tengan explota el cuerpo el país no
puede desarrollarse que no podemos tener
la estabilidad política en común sino a
esos problemas de las muchas lecciones
son los mismos grupos
por eso te pide en el país un momento de
ver efe jam para tomar una nueva
habitación y por eso necesitamos que el
mundo de la comunidad internacional de
los grupos del mundo amigos solidarios y
tienen realmente que hay entradas para
guardar
y la estabilidad y sin duda está en toda
la región cuando alguno de los
integrantes de la región estornuda pues
empieza a generarse en alguno de los
casos efecto de bola de nieve entonces
la salud política de haití pues va en
concordancia con la salud política de
toda la región en general así lo han
demostrado hechos en el pasado embajador
exile que piensa usted de esta forma que
tiene que actuar entonces la comunidad
internacional para ayudar a solventar
esta crisis desatada tras el asesinato
del presidente y vuelvo y le pregunto
qué papel debe jugar eeuu le pregunto
por eeuu porque es el gran aliado
internacional de haití así lo ha
demostrado también a lo largo de la
historia
para el efecto
en varias ocasiones y eeuu nos han
ayudado a conducir el país en buen
camino
wallis y lavado con nuestro ex
presidente rené préval teníamos los los
cascos azules que acompañaba pues en el
país durante un buen tiempo la idea por
las fuerzas oscuras que a él los
delincuentes digamos que están ahí en
este momento haciendo daño a la
población nos deben de acompañar en este
sentido para conducir el país a las
elecciones
paralelamente que la idea es invertir
para la educación del pueblo haitiano
para tener los pilares básicos sólidos
que es la educación la salud la vivienda
con eso
gradualmente vamos construyendo el país
entendiendo cómo está funcionando
el mundo y tener un país estable para un
futuro para el futuro embajador exit le
voy a decir tal vez la pregunta del
millón la pregunta de oro de este debate
y es quién puede estar detrás del
asesinato del presidente móvil había
información que el presidente desde
hacía varios meses estaba refugiado en
su casa privada no en la residencia
presidencial o en otro lugar estaba allí
porque había indicios tenía información
de que podía morir de que podía ser
asesinado en su propio país allí en su
propia casa efectivamente eso sucedió
solamente unos meses después de que el
mandatario decidió trasladar sus
funciones
actividad de la presidencia a su casa
que sabían ustedes en el gobierno sobre
estas amenazas que sabían ustedes al
interior del cuerpo diplomático de lo
que podía sucederle al presidente
la autoridad haitiana en este momento
están haciendo todas las investigaciones
pertinentes para determinar los grandes
autores intelectuales que están detrás
del magnicidio de nuestro presidente yo
en el país sin embargo durante
su mandato nosotros podemos darnos
cuenta de tantas cosas que han pasado
en el dinero donde muchos sectores nunca
han estado de acuerdo con él donde él ha
tenido unas decisiones muy radicales en
contra de empresarios contra diferentes
grupos que interactúan en el país hace
dos meses había un complot en contra de
él donde alcanzaron a detectarlo y pues
en este caso se salvó la vida del
presidente pero en esta oportunidad fue
muy bien montado listo con bastante
cómplices y se levarán con la vida del
presidente más rápidamente embajador xxi
le abría de pronto traición al interior
de las filas del gobierno hacia el
presidente
yo creo para un presidente solamente
morirse todos los que están al herido
pues se salvaron
eso dice muchas cosas no podía hacerlo
que solamente al presidente mueve muchas
personas deberían de morir antes de
llegar sobre el presidente no puede ser
el único caso y todos el monto del mundo
se salva no
si usted está allí en puerto príncipe
usted puede ver el día a día de los
haitianos desde que comenzaron las
manifestaciones contra el presidente
maurice y las secuelas que ha traído la
pandemia del comil 19 que ha
profundizado la crisis social la crisis
política la crisis económica para usted
quiénes pueden estar detrás de este
asesinato
vuelvo y pregunto traición empresarios o
grupos de la oposición o simplemente
delincuencia que se ha multiplicado con
el paso de los meses allí en este país
lo vemos en las noticias a diario
secuestros atracos y mucha inseguridad
en las calles del centro de puerto
príncipe
tiene en mí tenemos muchas preguntas
también y no nos ponemos de entender
como por ejemplo un grupo compuesto
según lo que se dice y es para miedos
pueden entrar tan fácilmente dentro de
la residencia privada del presidente
matarlo y él a su esposa así todo el
mundo hablan de traición de complicidad
a rentó el campo del presidente de su
equipo dice ese punto porque al cuerpo
en lo que tiene que ver con los
extranjeros y para hablando
tenemos mucho miedo para que realmente
los que atacan a cualquier persona con
el color de su piel o porque este
extranjero y porque en el país y el
gobierno y ha vendido le habían traído a
gente extranjeros armados en el barrio a
veces y eso fue denunciarlo por la
función con el paramento sí que hemos
tenido en ninguna explicación sobre el
papel de esas personas arman a tener
país y si por ejemplo un buen grupo que
fue al estar fuera de comicidad
estallaron como diplomáticos si en el
país ni tiene sólo yo pienso que en
todas en la impunidad también del mismo
presidente y gobierno
y están desplazando a la población
hispana han hecho 13 más en los barrios
populares desde los dos últimos años
para la puesta de personas a moverse sin
que el gobierno diga nada
de imputar
de regreso con usted embajador exile
hace unos minutos la agencia reuters
emitió una alerta en la que cita al jefe
de la policía nacional de haití diciendo
que 28 de estos mercenarios que
posiblemente entraron al país de manera
irregular ya fueron identificados y 26
de ellos son de nacionalidad colombiana
dos de ellos son de nacionalidad
haitiana qué repercusiones va a traer
esto en la relación entre bogotá y
puerto príncipe- países que han sido
cercanos también a lo largo de la
historia incluso tienen
frontera marítima entre los dos países
esto puede desencadenar una crisis
internacional entre estas dos naciones
bueno el pueblo colombiano yo que estoy
acá es muy querido muy abierto
para ayudar a haití el pueblo colombiano
por en el caso mío personalmente en
todas las instancias que yo llego
siempre es puerta abierta siempre a
nivel educación a nivel empresarial todo
el mundo me quiere ayudar haití ellas
muchas veces toman esas diferencias de
repitió en bolívar como en prisión había
ayudado a publicarla obtener la
independencia siempre manifiesta el
pueblo colombiano que tienen una deuda
hacia los haitianos
[Música]
no interrumpa pero es que en esta
oportunidad un grupo de 26 mercenarios
colombianos habrían participado en el
asesinato del presidente en funciones
perfecto en este caso de las 26
pues de 26 personas que dicen que es de
esta nacionalidad lo que yo
personalmente estoy haciendo es
identificar
número de pasaporte las personas quienes
son etcétera para que el gobierno
colombiano procede pues en este caso
no van a hacer ningún tipo de denuncia
reclamo ante las autoridades colombianas
ahí estoy esperando
el resultado las investigaciones sería a
partir del resultado llevamos a cabo el
proceso que se debe de hacer con el
regreso con usted en puerto príncipe
para preguntarle la para entrar en la
recta final del programa para las
conclusiones en qué va a pasar en este
país desde su perspectiva va a haber
elecciones libres en septiembre va a
haber posesión presidencial en febrero
va a haber inestabilidad profundizada a
lo largo de estos meses hasta febrero o
se va a agudizar la inseguridad y la
inestabilidad o el país va a poder
respirar
no revelase soler en diciembre realmente
las condiciones muy es para los de oliva
y las instituciones internacionales
están en eso saben realmente que no es
posible hacer parte blasco pero pienso
que el equipo debe hacer todo lo posible
para evitar una nueva terminal y
aprovechó para denunciar la demanda
hecha hoy indiferente al consejo de
seguridad
el señor diseñando una nueva internación
y nadie yo quiero la cuchara de contacto
del mundo que admisiones de las naciones
unidas en life desde 15 años como tiene
dos amigos de la minutos latinos ahora
tenemos la misión de las naciones unidas
en haití y no mandan admitido realmente
cambiar nada me establecerá el país
realizar el país ni siquiera de lugar
las instituciones todas las
instituciones están varadas quieren y
realmente andamos no es una nueva
invasión que necesitamos cuando ya están
las organizaciones de naciones unidas
su novia evaluación
[Música]
sí embajador exit rápidamente para el
cierre 50 segundos conclusión de lo que
puede suceder
conclusión de lo que puede suceder
debemos de tomar conciencia de todos los
actores políticos haitianos toda la
gente todos los empresarios etcétera
para conducir el país en otro camino no
podemos pasar a otra generación más
peleando por
cosas que nos llevan que no nos llevan
absolutamente nada somos una generación
totalmente perdida en mi compatriota
cole también ha sido víctima seguramente
pues de lo que está pasando donde no
tenemos educación no tenemos
instituciones fortalecidas hay
seguramente factores exógenos que impide
que el país avanza pero debemos de tomar
conciencia que somos haitianos
debemos construir el país para que
nuestros hijos nuestros futuros hijos
que viven en una situación totalmente
diferente de lo que nosotros pasamos
durante ellos
pues tienen ahí ustedes las opiniones de
nuestros dos invitados de la situación
que se está viviendo en haití en este
momento
colletti al embajador ex y les agradezco
por haber estado con nosotros gracias a
ustedes por la sintonía
gracias
[Música]